what is up everybody this is kevin
johnson from the community team here at
blizzard entertainment today we have a
real treat for you as will be taking a
first look inside the heroes of the
storm alpha please keep in mind that
this is a very early build of the game
and as such is a work in progress much
of what you see here will be changing as
the game develops well there's a lot to
get to so let's jump in as soon as you
boot up into the game you're immediately
taken to a tutorial that walks you
through the basics the tutorial will
give you all the info you need to get
started playing from character movement
to intro tactics and don't worry Luther
isn't really gonna sound like that thank
the light another hero when you finish
the tutorial you'll unlock quests quests
are specific challenges that grant
experience points are XP when you
complete them daily quests unlock each
day offering new challenges across the
game we even offer quests unique to each
hero that help you unlock additional
skin variations not only do quests grant
you XP but some quests even unlock
additional modes and features when you
complete them alright so continuing
through the UI prompts will bring you to
the game's current home screen one of
the first things you will notice is the
visual progression of your account level
shown at the bottom of the screen this
will give you a quick snapshot of where
you currently sit in a leveling
experience and provide goals to shoot
for in order to unlock various game
features in the top right hand corner of
the screen you'll find your quest log
this is where you'll find your active
quests that we described earlier your
menu where you'll find options related
to gameplay graphics sound and more is
also located here in the lower right
hand corner of the screen or the game's
current social features the far right is
your friends list you can add friends to
your list by either using their account
email address or their Blizzard
battletag next to your friends list is
the party tab Heroes is a game that
really shines when you're playing with
friends or people you've met using the
game's matchmaker this window is the
place to kick off a party from your
friends list or add new members to fill
one out up at the top of the screen
you'll find the watch tab while this
menu is not yet available we are looking
to support some of the awesome replay
features currently found
starcraft 2 along with some fancy new
ones as we get further in development
now let's jump into a game if you click
on the play tab at the top of the screen
you'll be brought to a screen that gives
you a variety of different game modes
practice cooperative and vs let's start
with practice mode practice mode pits
you in for computer-controlled allies
against a full team of
computer-controlled enemies this is a
great mode to start off on and gives you
the full heroes experience without the
added pressure of playing against other
people this is the hero select screen
you can select from available heroes at
the top of the screen simply click on a
desired heroes portrait or choose the
question mark on the left to queue up as
random the heroes that are available to
you our heroes you have purchased along
with heroes that are currently part of
our ongoing free hero rotations we'll
talk more about that later clicking on
the hero details in the lower left
corner of the screen will bring up a
variety of specifics about your hero
this green will be changing quite a bit
but the game's development for now you
can view your heroes abilities their
various mounts skins and skin variations
every skin that you purchase will have
skin variations that change the color of
that skin you unlock the ability to
access these variations by completing
quests specific to each hero when you
have your hero selected and you're ready
to do battle hit the ready button to get
started once you complete your first
practice match you'll be awarded
experience for your efforts and you'll
unlock cooperative mode cooperative mode
pits you in for other live players
against the team of AI opponents this
mode will introduce you to playing with
live teammates and further prepare you
for play against a team of real
opponents if you want you can directly
invite players to your party from here
by clicking on the purple invite buttons
you see on the screen if you don't have
a friends list to pull from no worries
cooperative mode is designed to match
you with equally skilled allies using
the game's matchmaker Valley Road will
even be working to line up the AI
difficulty to match your team's level of
skill the hero you selected is the hero
you will play in game with others you
choose who you want to play before you
ever start queuing whenever you finish a
game with live allies you'll have an
option after the game to invite players
you enjoyed playing with to join your
party
this feature can help you find skilled
players you can formally party with not
just for your next game but possibly
others in the future okay so now you've
unlocked versus as you might expect
versus is where we put you and for the
live players into battle with other
player teams here you have all the same
options as before check out heroes
invite friends or dive into a game it is
important to note however that while
ranked mode will eventually be coming
for vs play it is not yet implemented
next let's take a quick look at the shop
where you can check out heroes skins and
mounts by default you brought to the
hero shop where you can click on the
left and right arrows to browse heroes
available for purchase or navigate using
these Rock and hexagons if you want
there is also a search option that lets
you browse heroes by their franchise
hero named hero role and hero title you
can also sort all of the heroes
alphabetically by their release date or
by price throughout the life of the game
we will be offering different groups of
heroes that you will be able to try free
of charge for a limited time we call
this our hero rotation and all heroes in
the current rotation are marked with an
icon so you can easily spot them when
you click on a hero you will be taken to
that heroes page you can easily see the
hero's name what their awesome title is
which Blizzard franchise they represent
and all abilities a hero can perform you
can also spend your hero around to check
out their model in fact the model you
see here is exactly the same model used
in game if you want to test a hero and
their abilities before you purchase it
click on the try button at the bottom of
the heroes page this takes you to a
sandbox map where you have complete
control over millions spawning objective
control and ability cooldowns we think
it's important that you have a chance to
try out a hero in battle before making a
commitment to purchase once you've tried
a hero and are interested there are
options to purchase a hero using your
in-game gold or your battlenet balance
you can purchase heroes right away in
the cell phone while there will be
periodic account wipes as we progress
through testing anything you purchase
real money will be refunded to your
battlenet balance after a wipe if you
click on the appearance tab you can
check out all the skins and skin
variations available for your hero
finally you'll notice the talents tab
this page is definitely a work in
progress so expect a great deal more in
the future for now you can view the
leveling progression of your heroes
abilities here when shopping for skins
you have many of the same sorting
choices available to you as when
shopping for heroes you can search by
either the hero name or the skin name
you can also sort by all hero skins or
just skins for heroes that you own
clicking this drop-down menu lets you
sort skins in alphabetical order by
release date or by price just like our
heroes the skins you see are the exact
models available in game here you can
browse the different variations for a
skin if you're interested you can
purchase it down at the bottom of the
page finally you can also browse mounts
that are available for purchase under
the mounts tab alright folks that pretty
much wraps us up for this walkthrough we
are extremely excited to begin testing
this game publicly and look forward to
slowly but surely opening our doors to
increasing numbers of testers keep in
mind again everything you have seen here
is in an early alpha state and will most
likely change and evolve with time we
have additional features and technology
to bring to the table what you see here
is simply a starting point to support
the testing of our online infrastructure
stay tuned to heroes of the storm calm
for more information on our testing
plans and if you would like to be
considered for participation in this
alpha or our future beta tests be sure
to opt in via the links on our website
I'm Kevin Johnson for Blizzard
Entertainment we'll see you next time
you